we're going to begin with the news and
the disturbing new health numbers that
could affect millions of Americans it's
a growing Triple Threat they say of
illnesses putting millions of us at risk
reported covid-19 hospitalizations for
one they are up 20 percent in the past
week the flu also spiking with more than
a quarter of the nation's lab results
coming back positive and on top of those
cases we've got RSV also way up
hospitalizations for that respiratory
illness have more than quadrupled from
last year Carter Evans is at a hospital
outside Los Angeles a lot of hospitals
are stressed right now Carter good
morning
Good morning Tony yes RSV is hitting
kids very hard and Nationwide covet
numbers are still below what they were
at the height of the pandemic but
infections are rising dramatically in
some areas and once again Hospital
workers are being stretched thin
18.
General Hospital for Children in Boston
the Pediatric ICU is at 100 capacity and
most of the patients here are on oxygen
or ventilators this past year has been
unlike any other years in the past with
rsvcs in Staten way much earlier RSV or
respiratory syncytial virus is surging
along with the flu and covid-19
infections Nationwide Megan's 10 week
old son jack has been hospitalized with
RSV for nearly a week after he began
having trouble breathing his belly was
kind of sinking into his lower ribs so
that was the first really kind of big
scary moment it's really scary as a
parent to see that happening to your
baby
good while RSV may be peaking it's the
worst flu season in more than a decade
coming as coveted cases are again on the
rise the ER is inundated with cases and
people are being hospitalized in Los
Angeles County coveted cases have soared
75 percent in just the last week Douglas
chiraboga is a family medicine doctor
and he says the implications are clear
should there be another mandate in L.A
County I think there should be and I
think eventually we're going to have
their Mass mandated doctors say all
three of the now prevalent viral
infections sweeping the country could be
slowed by mask wearing and the time is
now to get your flu shot and covet
booster so far fewer than 13 percent of
Americans have received their updated
boosters a bad diagnosis according to Dr
chiraboga it tells me that people are
not getting the message
so keep in mind it takes a couple of
weeks after you get your vaccine for you
to become fully protected so do the math
you've got really just enough time right
now before all those Holly holiday
Gatherings and there is some good news
about baby Jack by the way he's expected
to head home from the hospital with his
mom today that's great that is great
right in time for the holidays Carter
thank you